le plus célèbre des commissaires le
commissaire moulin nous a quittés il
régnait décédé dans la nuit de vendredi
à samedi à l'âge de 78 ans la
disparition d'yves rénier un comédien
qui s'était aussi illustré en tant que
réalisateur il avait commencé sa
carrière au cinéma en 1961 dans le comte
de monte cristo et rencontré le succès
avec la série belphégor
je peux vous affirmer qu belphégor n'est
ni une apparition en une fable mais
c'est son rôle du commissaire moulin qui
l'incarnera pendant 30 ans qui lui fait
accéder à sa notoriété
tout ce que je demande c'est de répondre
oui ou non à ma question d'accord yves
rénier était aussi connu pour son franc
parler ses nombreux coups de gueule
le comédien il passa réalisateur et en
2018 son téléfilm jacqueline sauvage
c'était lui ou moi avec muriel robin
avait réalisé la meilleure audience de
l'année pour une fiction française for
lan les 9 millions de téléspectateurs
sur tf1 en mars dernier c'est son
téléfilm la traque inspiré de la sphère
michel fourniret qui avait suscité de
nombreux débats et qui restera sa
dernière création alors il nous reste
qu'une chose à vous dire adieu au
commissaire daniel angeli merci d'être
avec nous ce soir
non merci à vous parce que vous êtes
exister le plus proche d'yves rénier
vous êtes vous avez réalisé une
cinquante de une de paris match
il est y est très très proche de lui
vous avez appris sa disparition comment
j'ai appris par mes enfants parce qu'on
avait un peu des points communs active
de nos femmes ont été enceintes en même
temps d'accord de deux garçons donc ils
sont quatre et c'est mon fils qui m'a
appelé voilà et puis après c'est tombé
sur les succès tomber sur les fm tv
enfin et cgc chez fondre et je vois en
étaient plus calmes un ami c'était un
peu un frère un grand frère je sais pas
j'ai j'arrive pas à penser à croire
qu'il est parti c'est très difficile
pour moi pour mes enfants pour ça je
pense à tout le monde sa femme enfin et
c'est assez
bon bernard qu'elle a le caennais c'est
mieux aussi
bernard j'ai travaillé avec lui j'ai
fait ou bien on sort daniel vraiment
j'ai vu daniel rentrée sur le plateau il
est il est effondré
c'est vrai qu'on s'y attendait pas du
tout isabelle machette je sais que vous
étiez proche aussi de oui moi ya trois
semaines quand il est venu airtel
c'était la dernière interview et bernard
l'avant dernière honnêtement je les
trouvais tellement fatigué que
j'appelais tf1 après en disant je n'ose
pas appeler karim et il n'est pas il
était vraiment fatigué par le tournage
par mois honnêtement j'étais inquiète
effectivement je l'adorais cette oreille
alors on va reparler dans un instant on
reste avec nous daniel merci d'être avec
nous ce soir est très heureux de vous
avoir
merci encore une fois je vous dire est
ce qu a plein de gens comme on avait un
peu critiqué mais c'était pas contre lui
le téléfilm sur michel fourniret ya des
gens qui croyaient qu'on avait pas yves
rénier et c'est vrai que je le dis en
présence de bernard j'ai demandé
d'ailleurs juste après cette séquence
d'envoyer un sms à yvon lui disant tu
sais cyril et des thèmes beaucoup il a
été très fan de toi c'était juste
continuer là c'était juste et on se
demandait si c'était la bonne
programmation mais au contraire voilà et
je sais que vous le voyez je l'avais dit
j'avais dit en phase avec lui voilà vous
avez très bien pris we made in lendemain
qu est-ce qui m'ont mis maigrir parce
qu'ils savaient positive est tout ouïe
la lutte n'était pas contre lui en plus
et voilà mais je vous adore mais voilà
ça m'a vraiment moi et je vous dis ça
maintenant je lui avais dit il était
très très heureux d'entendre ça
évidemment mais on voudrait que toutes
les critiques l'avait beaucoup touchée
sur la sphère fournir et on aura plus
c'était les débuts de la sphère fournir
et les gens n'avaient pas compris ça au
début de chaussée isabelle que vous
étiez très peur j'étais d'ailleurs chez
jean marc morandini ce matin pour en
parler très bref je crois que c'est vous
qui avez fait la dernière interview
l'avant dernier à une heure près avec
magna mais c'est vrai car on s'est
appelé après aussi vous dire comment tu
l'as trouvé c'est pas daniel c'est quoi
le fond c'est un acteur un réalisateur
formidable c'est vous le disais tout à
l'heure que son votre plus grand regret
ce serait qu'il ait passé qui n'est pas
réalisé un grand film au cinéma
oui parce que bon il ya eu l'histoire de
36 quai des orfèvres qui
c'était une idée à lui à la base voilà
oui didier marchal longtemps ils sont
réconciliés bon voilà quoi
mais il avait un tel talent de metteur
en scène que c'est un grand regret pour
moi quoi qu'il ait pas fait un tournage
au cinéma il était acteur de mode en
plein de films mais il n'a pas mis en
scène au cinéma ça me on le voyait
toujours sourire avec une boîte
formidable je sais qui il a un gros
regret bernal bernard leleu grand regret
que sa vie à yves rénier je sais que
c'est c'est si incroyable mais c'est
quoi
il ya une très très grande tristesse
effectivement c'était de ne pas pouvoir
assister à l'enterrement de johnny parce
que johnny était très mal vécu la très
très mal vécu c'est même su qu'il avait
vraiment beaucoup beaucoup pleuré même
ce qui est rare parce que bon c'est un
homme qui est intime intime estime c'est
vrai ils sont devenus intime parce que
quand on a c'est moi qui ai amené il
veut m'a demandé de demander à johnny à
qui je suis et j'ai travaillé 20 ans de
tournée dans un moulin il ya eu une
réflexion de six mois puis il a accepté
et puis après bien sûr ils ont fait
ensemble la route 66 ils sont devenus
très très très très très bon et il
m'avait dit je vais avoir l'occasion du
tournage de commissaire moulin spéciale
johnny me dit je souhaite faire un
cadeau ce parce que c'était je pense
qu'il allait m'apporter un grigri et il
est arrivé à rtl avec johnny café une
1h30 de mission avec moi et ça change en
valeur du temps de johnny c'est un
cadeau immense il pensait et il n'a pas
été celle de dionis à la salle a plus
que bouleverser sa la chambouler
totalement mais en plus il faut dire
qu'il était extrêmement intime que même
il avait acheté une maison à saint barth
pour être tous ensemble
j'étais voisin moisin à saint barth il
se voyait tout le temps et puis bon je
suis donc ça a été compliqué avec
madame à l'idée d'un dessert histoire
ouais c'est ça l est les a vraiment fait
fâché et ça l'a vraiment mais vraiment
il a souffert il a vraiment beaucoup
souffert mais ils se voyaient en
cachette forte heureusement que johnny
mais bien faire les choses en cachette
toute façon souvent et il se voyait
quand même mais ça il a beaucoup
souffert je sais et je vois même sur rfm
quand je lui ai posé la question j'ai
dit je crois à yves que tu as eu
beaucoup souffert de ne pas assister à
l'enterrement
il me dit s'il te plait je ne veux pas
répondre je veux pas en parler mais oui
ça va il paraît que johnny blaze b10
toujours en cachette ça ces îles qui me
l'avait raconté tu peux venir mais à
cause d'une brouille entre des femmes
sans ta femme et moi je viens je viens
pas du tout et donc il n'est plus enfin
il faut dire que s'entraîner dix mois il
aurait dit c'est quelqu'un d'important
parce que moi très très jeune j'ai rêvé
avec lui je les ai vus dans les dents
belphégor avec juliette gréco ou j'étais
terrorisée à l'époque sting un
feuilleton de claude barma qui passait
l'été vie en noir et blanc
ça faisait des millions de
téléspectateurs ensuite les
globe-trotters et puis tout un tas de
films dont bien sûr est ce que
maintenant on le sait mais j'aurais aimé
lui dire vous 3 avant qu'ils partent
mais moi je l' ai vu un toute façon donc
que moi il a compris que je l'aimé
d'abord que parce que j'aimais aussi son
dernier film james qui fait et en fait
sa dernière apparition aller dans les
homes ati vous savez avec richard heck
gens l'ont été jeudi dernier non jamais
déjeuner avec lui à trois mois je crois
de trois mois il était il sérieux
il aimait il aimait il est il prenait
les choses d'une certaine manière en
chef des flèches compte pour les gens
faits mais quand on le connaît c'est
qu'elle s'était un bonhomme c'est un
grand il était un peu bougon parce que
par exemple il était capable de se lever
de table - tu sais quand il en avait
marre de tawila et se coucher et ça ça
m'a toujours amusé moi c'est un truc
c'est vrai il or ces chiens tristes
incidents y préparer un téléfilm sur le
droit de mourir dans la dignité en fin
de vie dont yves rénier avait quatre
enfants que l'on pose beaucoup ce soir
samantha qui est aussi actrice tôt la
julie oscars on pense bien sûr à sa
femme merci en tout cas daniel est ce
que vous avez un dernier mot à dire
daniel ce soir pour à nos
téléspectateurs sur yves au revoir mon
pote d'augmenter
c'est plus que ce à quoi s'est pas voilà
j'ai dû j'ai beaucoup de mal à croire
qu'il est qui est plus là merci daniel
d'avoir été avec nous ce soir merci
encore
[Applaudissements]